so mr product studios teamed up with
rapper lil nasdaq to
modify some nike shoes that were made
with a splash of real human blood
nike says just don't do it and following
in the footsteps of cultural icons like
17th century poet john milton and
madonna the singer not the other one lil
nazex dropped a music video where he
evokes satan's fall
into hell by descending into hell
himself
via stripper pole i don't think that is
actually in
paradise lost but along the way little
nasex wears modified nike air max 97s
mischief product studios was responsible
for modding the shoes
adding occult references like 666 a
pentagram bible verses and red ink oh
and of course the midsole of each shoe
contains exactly one drop
of human blood but when mischief offered
666 pairs of shoes for sale
nike responded quickly by suing mischief
for trademark infringement so the
question is
what the hell is going on
[Music]
sponsored by skillshare hey legal eagles
it's time to think like a lawyer because
the devil is in the details
and what is going on with this suit what
does it mean for sneakerheads in general
is it illegal to modify a consumer
product and resell it
does this mean that you can't sell
modified nikes anymore or any other kind
of modified clothing
well we're going to get into all of that
today because this is a fascinating case
that
just involves just about everything but
first a point of clarification because a
lot of people think that this case
involves copyright and that's simply not
the case there are generally three kinds
of
intellectual property or ip that people
think about there's copyright patent and
trademark
copyright involves things that are
expressive
things like art books tv shows movies
that gets copyright protection
then there's patents that tends to cover
useful items things like
inventions and then finally that leaves
trademark which is meant to protect the
consumer public it's meant to uh show
people where things came from by
creating brands so that they know
the source of the things that they are
buying and in order to qualify for
trademark protection under federal law
a trademark has to meet three basic
requirements one the trademark has to be
distinctive of the source of the goods
or services
to which it is affixed number two the
trademark must not be
disqualified from protection by various
statutory bars to protection
number three the trademark has to be
used in commerce
the purpose of trademark is to identify
the source of goods to ensure that
consumers actually know where their
products come from in other words
trademark holders get protection from
people and companies who would sell
knock-off goods it's all about
protecting the consumer public
and that's what this whole lawsuit is
about nike has invested billions of
dollars into its brand and is trying to
protect the strength
of the swoosh and the nike word mark so
that people aren't confused
and people don't think that nike created
some shoes that are endorsed by satan
you can sort of understand where they're
coming from on that and in nike's
lawsuit it immediately dissociates
itself from the satan's shoes
mischief is currently taking orders for
the shoes it refers to as the satan
shoes which are customized nike air max
97 shoes that mischief has materially
altered to prominently feature a satanic
theme
this was done without nike's approval or
authorization and nike is in no way
connected to this project
so nike brings a bunch of claims and the
first of which is garden variety
trademark infringement in violation of
15 usc
1114 and nike claims that mischief
products violated nike's trademark
by manufacturing and selling satan's
shoes so how do you prove trademark
infringement well to prevail on a claim
of trademark infringement a company has
to show
one it owns a valid trademark number two
that the defendant used the trademark in
commerce without the company's consent
and three the defendant's use created a
likelihood of consumer confusion the key
element
is the third one that there is a
likelihood that a consumer will be
confused about the source of the goods
and nike objects that it has no control
over the nature and quality of the
satan's shoes and that it has a
reputation and goodwill
that will be damaged if mischief keeps
selling these modified nikes
and consumers are likely to be confused
by the shoes and any defects objections
or faults with the shoes that
might hurt nike's reputation and nike of
course especially objects to the blood
in the midsole
which could pose a risk of harm to the
consumer but this isn't your
garden-variety trademark infringement
case where some nefarious competitor
is creating another product and
intentionally creating it in a way
that's confusing to people
creating a bunch of shoes that have a
check mark on it that kind of looks like
a nike swoosh
instead mischief actually bought nikes
they were originally nikes it's just
that they
modified them after the fact which
brings up the most common defense in a
case like this which is called the first
sale doctrine
when people started hearing about this
nike suit a lot of people were worried
that that meant that
if nike can sue you you can't buy a
consumer good and then
resell it let's say used on ebay or
maybe resell it new
on amazon but generally the first sale
doctrine means that it's legal for an
individual to resell a
trademarked item after it has been sold
by the trademark owner in an authorized
sale
so when you buy an authentic pair of
nikes you can usually do what you want
with them in fact
anytime you buy a branded good it
becomes yours
if you want to buy a book and later sell
it on ebay the author can't stop you
you can keep it forever and maybe give
it to goodwill sell it on ebay or throw
it in a like it's yours to do with what
you want
and trademark law is supposed to protect
consumers from being deceived about the
origin of a product
are consumers confused when they buy the
genuine article with an authentic
trademark
generally no they're not and that's why
a mark holder can't stop you from
reselling
a used item that's the whole purpose of
the first sale doctrine and there are a
couple of exceptions to the first sale
doctrine for the purposes of nike's
lawsuit the most important one applies
when the products sold
are materially different from the
company's authorized product
nike says that its shoes were materially
altered to prominently feature a
satanic theme and so how do you prove
material difference well in 2020
one court described it this way an
alteration is material if it changes
something about the product that is
relevant to a consumer's decision to
purchase
that product that quote is from a case
where maui jim the sunglass manufacturer
sued someone who was reselling their
sunglasses but they
removed the lenses from the frames and
replaced them with different lenses
generally either plano lenses or
prescription lenses
the problem from maui jim's perspective
was that they had patented the lenses to
promise to wipe out glare and uv rays
and the skin cancer foundation
officially recommended the maui gems as
an effective uv filter for the eyes and
surrounding skin
so maui jim didn't want people buying
these
modified sunglasses without the
protections that they had designed
into their original glasses and maui jim
successfully argued that by replacing
the lenses with something else
the this reseller had removed something
that factored into a person's decision
to buy maui jim
frames so to bring it back around to the
satan shoes nike is arguing that
confusion has already resulted because
this
unauthorized reseller and modifier of
shoes is offering original nike shoes
without the associated benefits that
nike customers expect and
it has been materially modified nike
says that adding an extra substance like
blood to the midsole of the shoe
could pose safety risks to the consumer
and of course nike also implies that
lots and lots of consumers are disgusted
by the ideas of shoes with blood in them
and yeah if you're selling nike air
shoes they're supposed to have an air
pocket in the sole of the shoe and it's
actually filled with liquid regardless
of whatever that liquid is
that kind of seems like a material
difference but nike's second claim is
for false designation of origin which is
generally a fancy name for consumer
confusion
according to nike consumers are already
being misled into believing that nike
was deliberately promoting satan's shoes
the company can cite hundreds of posts
from christians who are now questioning
whether nike is promoting satan they can
also find
plenty of people who object to having
shoes made with blood in them
and i have to admit when i first saw the
headlines for this case i thought nike
had manufactured the shoes
there's a prominent white nike swoosh on
a black shoe
i thought that nike had done this
collaboration and as nike says
as an innovative brand that strives to
push the envelope and do the right thing
nike knows it may not please everyone at
all time but decisions about what
products to put the swoosh on belong to
nike
but on the other hand generally when
you're talking about consumer confusion
you're talking about point of sale
confusion that the people who bought the
actual products
were misled into thinking that there was
some association there and it's actually
sort of unlikely that the over 600
people that bought
the modified shoe thought that nike had
created the shoe
it seems like they knew that mischief
was the one that modified those shoes
so it's hard to argue that they the
consumers the direct consumers of these
shoes were confused in any other way
though on the other other hand nike
would argue that
regardless of whether these consumers
were confused downstream consumers
the public at large will think that nike
had something to do with his satan shoes
and thus potentially not
buy nike shoes in the future and then we
get to nike's third and my
favorite trademark related claim one for
trademark dilution
and i know i joke on this channel a lot
about claims being particularly sexy
but this claim is actually literally
sexy and we'll get to that in just a
second
but in 1996 congress enacted the federal
trademark dilution act
which made it possible for mark holders
to obtain injunctions against the use of
their marks
even if there is no traditional
trademark infringement and the ftda
gives certain mark holders the right to
sue when a third party uses a mark
in commerce in such a way that it hurts
consumer perception of
a famous mark and there are generally
two kinds of dilution there's blurring
and there's tarnishment
and blurring is when a famous mark's
distinctiveness is harmed because it
becomes or is likely to become
associated with a similar mark in a
different context so for example
if rolex was suddenly stamped on golf
balls and
hot dogs in addition to watches then
there would be blurring of that mark you
might associate rolex with hot dogs
instead of
fancy watches and tarnishment on the
other hand happens when the famous
mark's reputation is harmed
through an association it tarnishment
creates a harm to a famous mark by
associating it with something that would
damage that reputation so normally
that's when a famous mark is linked with
something that is considered offensive
like pornography or drug use and courts
are especially hard on expressions that
link a product to
sex i told you we were going to get
actually sexy with this legal claim
so for example barbie won a case against
a porn company that wanted to have
barbie in their url
and the dallas cowboy cheerleaders won a
case against the movie www's dallas
because
it used dallas cowboy cheerleader style
outfits in
a very adult film and a website was not
allowed to use the domain name
candyland.com to identify porn site
because it tarnished and diluted the
hasbro candyland trademark associated
with its board games
but if the subject is not sex then
courts are not completely consistent in
how they decide
whether there is actual tarnishment and
dilution so for example in one case
parodies involving dog chew toys were
protected speech
the ninth circuit held that a squeaking
dog toy resembling a bottle of jack
daniel's whiskey
is an expressive work entitled to first
amendment protection while a virginia
court held that louis vuitton's mark was
not tarnished by a company selling
chewy futon squeaky dog toys but on the
other hand dr seuss was able to stop
publication of an o.j simpson trial
parody book called
the cat not in the hat by dr juice the
court found a likelihood of confusion
and stopped publication that case
involved both copyright and trademark
aspects you really could write a whole
book on how
dr seuss enterprises vigorously defends
its rights through
lawsuits but in contrast the banned aqua
was victorious in a battle with mattel
over the song barbie girl
where the ninth circuit held that the
song about barbie did not turn barbie
into a sex object nor did
its lyrics tarnish barbie's reputation
but nike claims that mischief's wrongful
use of the nike asserted marks in
connection with his satanic imagery is
likely to cause dilution by
tarnishment which understandably could
theoretically damage
nike's reputation and as i said courts
take a very puritanical view when it
comes to associations with sex
but we don't know exactly what the
court's going to think about using
satanic imagery on a shoe whether that's
offensive or unsavory in the same way
that pornography or criminality would be
but nike probably has a decent chance of
prevailing on this
so let's talk about mischief's defenses
here in its response to nike's motion
for temporary restraining order which
i'll get to in a few moments
mischief says that nike cannot show
confusion among sophisticated purchasers
of sneakers
who all knew all along that this was a
collab between lil nas x and mischief
with no nike involvement but nike's
counter to this is that nike's logo
is all over the shoes in question and as
for nike's claim that its brand is being
tarnished by an association with satan
mischief argues about the prior shoes
that it created it created a line
of jesus shoes white shoes with cross
iconography and filled with
supposedly blue holy water and says that
those shoes were not universally
embraced
but nike didn't try and enforce their
rights against that particular
modified shoe and on the contrary many
people were outraged by the
these jesus shoes and labeled them as
sacrilegious
and like nike mischief has tweets
backing up its position and here's one
pointing out that nike is named for the
greek goddess of victory which at least
one twitter user found to be offensive
and here's one saying that the jesus
shoes made the user sick and he intended
to throw away
all of his nike gear so nike can't win
with associations with other non-satanic
deities and mr's point here is that they
can probably
find tweets hammering nike no matter
what choice they make and
people have criticized nike for
manufacturing sneakers in china but when
nike criticized china's forced labor
camps earlier this year chinese
celebrities publicly cut ties with the
company
so nike is frequently the subject of
debate and controversy
those who are convinced nike is a
horrible company are unlikely to be
swayed by the satan's shoes
and that of course brings us to the
first amendment because just because
something is a trademark or is involved
in commerce doesn't mean that you give
up all first amendment rights
trademarks of course are meant to
protect against consumer confusion
but in recent years courts are
increasingly likely to find that the
first amendment protects speech even
when it might naturally result in some
confusion
and that's a good thing for artists like
little nas x and mischief nike of course
claims that the satan's shoes are not a
piece
of art and were not created by artists
and are just purely a commercial venture
saying well mischief has a first
amendment right to criticize
discriminatory social norms
those norms have nothing to do with the
nike swoosh and the nike word mark but
at base there's clearly some tension
between trying to
protect trademarks and one's first
amendment right to expression
which takes us to the parody defense
just as
fair use is a defense to copyright
infringement parody is a defense to
some kinds of trademark dilution claims
but parity in the trademark context is
not easy to prove
the elements that you have to show are
one in original host work too the
original work must be famous or well
known within the particular target
audience
and three the creator of the derivative
work the parody must take only so much
of the original work as is necessary to
bring to mind the original host work
and for the derivative work which
conjures up the famous mark must result
in a new
original work so let's break this down
further this is difficult in this
context because the parody has to be
making fun
of a real product here nike shoes it
can't just be a parody of something else
like
religion for example and it has to be
obvious to consumers that the parody is
making a comment on the real product
and the second message must be something
like yes these are authentic nike shoes
and isn't nike ridiculous with the way
they use their brand
so there has to be an element of satire
joking or reverend commentary that the
consumer would understand and this is a
really interesting issue for
mischief because as we talked about
before a traditional trademark case
cares about confusion at the point of
sale where the people who bought the
satan's shoes confused at all about the
source
probably not the buyers knew that
mischief had created a parody making fun
of nike itself the argument being that
they're making fun of all the
collaborations that nike is willing to
do that they'll basically collaborate
with anyone even
jesus or satan and there are collectors
who
are well aware of what mischief does in
fact they may even be aware that
mischief once made jesus shoes with holy
water in the midsole and
nike didn't object and the jesus shoe is
interesting because it added a golden
jesus on a crucifix as a shoelace charm
and
mischief also sourced holy water from
the river jordan which was apparently
blessed by a priest in brooklyn
and added it to the soul of the shoe and
in a press release
mischief founder said that he was
commenting on the ridiculous
collaborations that nike has done we
asked ourselves what would a shoe collab
with jesus actually look like obviously
it would let you walk on water well how
can we do that you pump holy water into
the pocket of
air of the air max 97s and with that you
get the jesus shoe
the holiest collab ever and that makes
the jesus shoe and the satan shoes feel
more
like a parody maybe the satan shoe
buyers were aware of this history of
weird collabs and even saw satan's shoes
as an extension of the earlier jesus
shoes
council for mischief expanded on this
argument in the company's tro letter
where mischief argues that the shoes
aren't mocking religion they are
mocking nike's reputation and nike is at
once a global icon
in a company with a reputation for shady
business practices like
making shoes using chinese sweatshops
and collaborating with just about anyone
to make a buck but
this logic may not hold up in court nike
can respond by saying that sure
the 666 consumers who purchased the
shoes weren't confused but everyone else
on the internet surely was and these
people matter because
they are future nike consumers who are
now confused they are literally saying
oh no nike loves satan
i have to burn my nikes again and that
takes us to the motion for a temporary
restraining order
nike was lightning fast with this
lawsuit filing almost the next day after
the shoes were released
and the day after that nike moved for a
temporary restraining order or an
injunction
to prevent mischief from doing anything
related to the shoes basically
nike wanted a temporary and permanent
injunctive to prevent
mischief from manufacturing transporting
promoting advertising publicizing
distributing ordering for sale or
selling any products including but not
limited to the satan shoes under nike
marks
and or any marks substantially
indistinguishable they're from
now we've talked about tros a lot on
this channel
generally the court only will issue this
emergency relief when there is
irreparable harm that cannot be undone
by the court
generally the idea is if you can be
compensated with money even
long after the fact that's not
irreparable harm
but ip is an area where courts often
find
irreparable harm it's harm to one's
reputation or brand that cannot be
undone and that's what nike is saying
here that their brand is being tarnished
by an association with satan
and you can't really undo that after the
fact but mischief argues that this
is inappropriate because mischief has
already shipped 665 of its 666 pairs of
shoes
with only one pair being held back for a
later raffle but it contends that since
the shoes have already shipped they've
gone out
emergency relief shouldn't be granted
well nike responded that even if the
company did ship
all but one of the pairs of shoes the
tro would still be necessary to
prevent that one other pair of shoes
going out and to prevent
mischief from benefiting from this
harmful and tarnishing
uh action that they've taken against
nike and nike accuses mischief
probably correctly of quickly shipping
the orders to circumvent the
possible incoming tro and to add injury
to insult mischief is now selling a
t-shirt
bearing the front page of nike's
complaint on the shirt that is
some creative marketing there and of
course nike accused mischief of
deliberately trying to stir up
controversy by promoting the t-shirt and
going forward with the shoe sale
despite having noticed that nike
believed that this was trademark
infringement but at the same time nike
didn't
technically notify mischief by letter or
phone call that it objected to the shoes
the company just simply went forward
with the lawsuit on the same day
of the sale but just like nike the court
moved lightning fast and within a day
issued a temporary restraining order
preventing mischief from really doing
anything related to the shoes but
here it's hard to unring the bell the
shoes are out mischief has
really benefited from all of the
publicity that it has gotten related to
the satan's shoes
and the associations have been made now
the court hasn't made a determination
on the merits a final one it found that
nike was likely to prevail if
this indeed goes forward but mischief
will be able to present
all of its arguments even those related
to the first amendment issues
uh in briefing related to a preliminary
injunction and eventually
the trial itself but if you want to
shoot a satan-themed music video that
may or may not be a parody you'll need
to learn how to shoot great video and no
one does that better than my friend
marquez brownlee who has a new class on
skillshare called script shoot and edit
with mkbhd
from initial concept to final cut
marquez will share his creative process
production workflow and favorite tools
like never before or if you want to
learn how to make your own satan shoes
you could take gigi rogers class
sneaker customizing for beginners and if
you want to write a blasphemous song you
can learn how to play guitar on
skillshare with my friend mike boyd's
class because skillshare has classes on
almost everything from video to business
to design
skillshare is an online learning
community that has tens of thousands of
classes on everything and
it's the best place to learn on the
internet so if you'd like to try out
skillshare the first 1000 legal eagles
to use the link in the description
we'll get a free trial of skillshare
premium and after that trial and
skillshare is still way more affordable
than
most online learning platforms with
plans starting at less than ten dollars
per month
plus clicking on that link really helps
out this channel so just click on the
link in the description to get a free
trial of skillshare premium but what do
you think is nike going to sue mischief
out of existence or is mischief just
engaged in first amendment protected
parody
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews
where i talk about the legal issues of
the day
including all of this crazy ip related
stuff so click on this playlist and i'll
see you
in court